there are 23 men and women cowering on
the forecourt of a shelter in Uganda
they're young and homeless and some are
sick
well well no no stupid but they are
treated with brutality by the
authorities because say human rights
groups they're gay these pictures
obtained by Sky News show the mayor of a
municipality near the capital Kampala
beating shelter residents with a
four-foot cane and he and his officials
taunt and interrogate those trembling
before them we've obscured the identity
of the shelter's occupants something the
authorities have been determined to
reveal however the official explanation
for this raid doesn't mention
homosexuality instead the shelter
manager and residents are accused of
spreading the corona virus and the
police bind their hands and tie them
together with rope and force marched
them to the municipal police station 19
people from the shelter were charged by
police and imprisoned and they've been
cut off from the outside world lawyers
haven't been permitted a single visit in
the past five weeks
Patricia Chimaera will lead their
defense like I said it was a trumped-up
charge during an act that is likely to
spread infection of disease these are
people who were found in a shelter in a
home a place that they take as home for
me I still believe that there was no
violation at all of any of the rules
Uganda's long time leader you weary
massive any casts himself as a man's man
doing press-ups in the presidential
office during the country's lockdown and
he's got no time for sexual equality
same-sex relationships are strictly
illegal still the United Nations Special
Rapporteur told me my 7yz administration
should release the 19 defendants the
release of this persons in response camp
Allah's police spokesman told us the
incident wasn't a raid it was a
community initiative targeting improper
social distancing the mayor declined to
give us a comment lawyers for the
defendants continue to seek their
release John sparks Sky News